salut il ya quelques jours j'étais en
tournée à grenoble en fait j'ai fait six
représentations à grenoble que tu es
complète merci à vous grenoble des fois
vous demandez ce qu'il ya dans le
spectacle et b ce qui envoie les
spectacles dites le dans les
commentaires mais grosso modo c'est un
spectacle d'humour durant une heure et
demie où je bluffe en même temps et vous
vous auto bleue fait des fois je ne peux
pas en dire plus je je suis sur écoute
et on pourrait la bad pour en dire plus
bref vous avez les dates de tournée la
description mais ce n'est pas le propos
c'est surtout qu'en étant là-bas on est
allé faire un escape game avec diablo
d'heure c'est mon régisseur des dozos et
comme j'étais à grenoble j'ai aussi
demandé à youtube six haletante et j'ai
pas pensé à demander à chris à poissons
fait qu'on l'a vue le lendemain
mais bref on s'est fait un petit
escalier une des familles alors
forcément on peut pas trop filmé dans un
escalier en tout cas on peut pas filmer
la résolution des énigmes mail escape
game arena m'a quand même permis de
sortir la caméra
merci à eux s'étaient pas obligé et je
vous ai demandé sur les réseaux sociaux
si vous préfériez que je mette des
passages de l'escalier une dans le blog
qui sort demain
d'ailleurs il soir demain matin ou si
vous préférez les gens fassent une vidéo
complète un peu rapide
vidéo un petit peu différente
aujourd'hui bon je vous ai demandé sur
les réseaux sociaux si vous m'avez pas
répondu de fait de me suivre sur
facebook twitter ou instagram et ça
c'est dans la description comme toujours
et vous m'avez répondu que vous
préfériez une vidéo isolé et ben c'est
celle ci et ben voilà
[Musique]
révélation vous allez enfin connaître la
vérité salue aujourd'hui je suis à un
escape game l'escabeau game escape arena
tu as vu à mon regard que j'ai regardé
parce que je me souvenais plus on vient
avec diablo et un petit invité surprise
du nom de youtube alias jordan mais faut
savoir un truc sur youtube je veux dire
rendez vous à 11h au 31 rue gustave
eiffel comme d'été 11 arrive n'était pas
là je les appelais une femelle or tu
m'as dit rendez-vous à 11h31 chaumet qui
dans ta vie tu te donne rendez-vous à
11h31 tu vois mais si tu m'as donné
rendez-vous à 11h31 rue gustave eiffel
je me dis si ça il n'a pas chopé cette
bonne info dans le sms
je pense qu'on va rester enfermé advitam
eternam dans les scop game du coup je
pense que youtube ci peut avoir deux
trois heures de retard février 2010 8
février 2019 il est de retour l'enfant
prodige de la musique de youtube est de
retour c'est youtube nous sommes pouvoir
tout retourné ça fait partie du jeu en
général mais là ces pièces là tout ce
qui est sur les murs vous aurez
interdiction d'y toucher
pour éviter que sa ruine des énigmes
pour vous derrière l'iphone qui trois
autres technologies regardez bien
maintenant vous êtes beaucoup plus
curieux que ça et vous vous dites que si
vous ont interdit de rentrer là dedans
c'est forcément qui a une raison et vous
voulez fouiller un petit peu cette pièce
mystérieuse pour voir si elles cachent
pas des choses intéressantes qu'une
chose soit claire 6 points ils
reviennent vous êtes encore à
l'intérieur
je ne sais pas ce que vous faites je ne
sais pas où vous êtes et c'est votre
problème
j'y vais robin bien sûr moi je vais dans
le bureau de pape hitman avec
le cousin louis c'est un sauna les mains
très sympa ce petit ce qui m'anime
alors on est censé trouver une feuille
les gars attend que je crois que je fais
partie des trucs regarde juste ici mais
j'ai pris dans la poche à loïc jour
vient de partir un bel orme qui nous
permettra de vendre les inscriptions
quelque part et peut-être sur la feuille
alors on est chez nous parle du bénin
c'est un bon départ je pense mais alors
tout les cas on est emmerdé si vous
retrouvez cette caméra
attention on a les clés geci basse
partout quatre ans le juste pour le jour
l'armoire mais prendre de très près
qu'on voit pas trop large
la presse m
j'adore la musique ça va mais c'est nous
appartient pas voilà venir vous avez
arrêté papier mais attention répartir
[Musique]
les lacs c'est ici
on a éteint son devoir
cinquante minutes pour rien quand c'est
navrant le coup de savate dambach d'être
[Musique]
c'est ici que le jeu commence on a déjà
mis une demi-heure
[Musique]
ça sent le narcotrafic en baisse à 1 blu
escobar et de l'auto alors là on est
dans une pièce vraiment chaude
non je sais maintenant qu'il brille ok
on a foi en vous je coupe un petit peu
dans la résolution des énigmes et les
amis c'est normal parce que si un jour
vous venez faire cet escalier mais ça
n'aurait aucun intérêt sinon bon là pour
l'instant on a ouvert un coffre on a eu
des documents ticker top secret et il
faut qu'on appelle le je sais pas quoi
mais la cx et c'est pour une carte
combat s'il vous plaît tu veux quoi le
psy est juste une bière avec le pepsi
pepsi et dans le calme et dans le pepsi
on va dire trois fois pepsi parce que
c'est un placement de produit voilà
merci
ok en fait on avance plus il n'en
fallait vous en appelant le msx la
lettre e
ça souffle web et avec un goût bien avec
nous sans déconner mais qu'il allait
fois il va sans dire en gros d'accord
avec le fait comme ça et
talent du lien avec nous en direct et
500 de vie
[Musique]
le général a sauté
arias
c'est d'occuper un rôle dans la crise
qui lui demandait si le voir sur votre
dos mitch a permis d aller mais continue
de traduire jeune maman merci des chiens
ils sont chiants vite vite vite vite il
arrive papy mamie c'est l'autre nom je
pense me mo
sans edwards en [ __ ] on est bon alors
et tu sais quoi bon
[Musique]
c'est là dans l'armée
où la france n'a pas
[Musique]
merci vous en
lula un des trois cci sur wii à 2 alors
que cossette quatre fromages et ce même
si presque impossible a dit à l'ats
pierre merci alors 57 minutes et 14
secondes et c'est bien des plusieurs
rues parce que tout s'est joué à pas
tous la même logique est ce que tu vas
pouvoir en 2024 suis encore là c'est sûr
mais on est en 2024
après cette folle partie une autre toile
partie s'annonce merci d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo j'espère que ça vous aura
plu c'est un chouette escape game parce
que le lait il est très immersif en fait
si vous avez l'occasion d'aller à
grenoble allez-y c'est pas une chaîne 10
4e c'est un privé n'est allé là bas un
petit peu par hasard mais c'était un
heureux hasard
l'équipe est cool et les énigmes sont
vraiment chouettes en ami 57 minutes à
sortir de l'upper big game
c'était donc pas si simple n'oubliez pas
si et seulement si la vidéo vous a plus
de mettre un live c'est très important
vous pouvez également vous abonner à la
chaîne si c'est pas encore fait et
rendez vous demain pour le vlog mensuel
ciao
[Musique]